hello hello
all right now we're back wow wow that
was really bad
welcome to the new bunker still
dealing with a lot of tech issues i
should move over a little bit here we go
i've got my light on and we have all
sorts of different things going on so
i'm really glad everybody's here we're
standing by for that was actually not a
joke sometimes i jokingly
i really did not know i was muted there
uh but we are live
we are live and that's the important
thing and uh
it's all fantastic what is going on
we're standing by for a big announcement
from joe biden
about vaccination momentarily
i want to say thank you to blue moon
maiden as well as inconsolable
for the twitch subs putting us on the
board right away
i think i have super chats on screen
i think there just aren't any yet last
time in the in the old bunker
it was tough to get them up on the
screen but now
we do have i think super chats up on the
screen
um we are about 30 minutes
from joe biden i did get vaccinated
people asking me of course i got my
second dose
on february uh 26th
and um was flu-like after both doses
and otherwise fine it lasted about i
don't know
18 hours or something like that um
oh there we go super chat okay is that
clear
on the screen for you guys because i see
it clearly
but it looks kind of weird up on the uh
uh up in stream labs
maybe there's so it is clear okay good
all right so it's just uh okay very good
fool in the rain says where are you
right now and why are you in this
location i can't say
and i can't say oh it's too small let's
see if we can make it a little bit
bigger
uh a lot of this stuff is
yeah i don't get why it looks like that
that's strange
um weird
yeah i don't know
it's kind of weird looking but it is
clear yeah the colors are strange it's
there's some kind of weird reversal
going on
um anyway we're all uh
we're all setting it up piece by piece
um and pear
sent a test super chat beautiful pair
love it
absolutely love it okay um i have
so many different things to go over
today i do have unban requests i have
i do want to talk about inflation
there's a big inflation headline
and republicans are going nuts and it's
really much ado about nothing and i'll
explain
why i want to look at the videos
of rand paul attempting to confront dr
fauci yesterday and it really didn't
go so well i want to look at cases and
deaths which are declining fortunately i
want to look at vaccination
which is starting to increase again i
also want to make a really strong
announcement
we are now dangerously close
to 200 000 whoa what is that
uh 200 why is this not even showing up
right
i can't scroll it what a mess oh my god
now it's getting even littler
little l-i-d-d-l-e as trump says wow
well we're really close to 200 000
twitter followers or i am and i am ready
to commit
today to doing an entire live stream
wearing absolutely no
socks if we get to 200 000 twitter
followers but i don't it's just this is
so everything is pathetic today i can't
even get it up on the screen
correctly um and somehow there's no
scrolling
what a mess oh there's one
okay uh anyway i will um
i will deal with that very strongly if
we ever get and there's no dark mode on
is there dark mode on social blade i
don't even know
maybe if uh 10 second milestone freeze
casino mode i don't know what this stuff
is guys i'm sorry
this is not a professional live stream
at all to the extent any of these have
been professional
this one is definitely not okay all
right good
so we're standing by for joe biden that
is next up and and we have a lot of
different things to talk about
okay let me get directly into
oh i have some of the most insane
voicemails not not from anybody that
we've banned like there's no
troy york you guys haven't heard from
troy york for weeks
but he's calling every single day i'm
just not subjecting you guys to it
because
you have decided no more troy york um
i do have a few voicemails to play
and i want to say thank you to
herbalation
for signing up via twitch i appreciate
that
and um okay
let's get right into my one unban
request
this is a user named tafe
leach who said
about oh okay this was the misgendering
uh teeth leech said on the last stream
about caitlyn jenner he thinks
he can make california a better state
than all governors before him
three misgenderings in one message to me
seemed deliberate so it was a ban for
deliberate misgendering
the unban request is no that was on me
and i take the ban wow this is pretty
pretty adult
that was on me and i take the ban it was
in poor taste and i apologize
caitlyn is a sore spot in my book and i
should not have done that
i usually don't say anything and my
buttons were pushed before i came in i
should have stayed quiet it was poor
taste
the apology is here and heart felt sorry
and you know they actually have a long
history on the channel
of completely reasonable participation
and they've been around for
for more than a year i'm inclined to
unban
i'm inclined to unban because they're
taking responsibility
and they they haven't they didn't just
create their account and come in
and misgender caitlyn jenner so i
i i i'm going to go with unbanned all
right unban
and confirm i have no pro
it's you know this is a uh somebody's
taking responsibility so i'm absolutely
fine with that they have been
unbanned and uh
that's it yeah please don't do it again
yeah i think the warning is an important
thing
don't do it again don't do it again all
right thanks to weslow and tiny aim as
well for the twitch subs
appreciate that guys and um
yes we will be doing all sorts of
different thank yous and all of that
everybody's very excited
okay let's get into the inflation stuff
okay um republic so here's what you have
to understand about this inflation thing
republicans for 30 years have been
saying
if democrats get their way all of their
spending will cl
create an inflationary spiral and at the
cost of everything will explode
that's been republicans for 30 years and
inflation has been very well controlled
in the united states for 30 years
the target inflation is about 2 percent
and i'll explain why in a moment
so today we get this news inflation
speeds up in april as consumer prices
leap 4.2 percent
fastest since 2008. what you really have
to understand about this
is that these are year-over-year
comparisons
so april prices compared
to last april prices what was go
this is what we call
critical thinking okay i needed to pause
there for effect because it's so
important
um what was going on in april of 2020 we
had one of the biggest demand collapses
because
we had coveted lockdown shutdown slash
whatever
start in mid in mid-march april was the
first major month of
people started working from home
restaurants were closed
construction was shut down et cetera et
cetera et cetera
so we're comparing prices now where we
have
rapidly declining cases rapidly
declining deaths
increased travel bookings increased
everything
compared to when we had an incredible
decrease in demand
so of course compared to a historic
economic shutdown
prices are now going to be higher okay
the question is um is this
4.2 percent of real inflation or is this
an artifact of what was going on
last year i believe that it is the
former now there is no question that
there are
some aspects some aspects
uh of uh of consumer pricing
that do seem to be more permanently
going up lumber
and a lot of construction related
products it seems like prices are going
to be elevated for for some time that
may be a real increase but
republicans remember republicans have
been saying the same thing for 30 years
obama's spending will create an
inflation spiral never happened
they didn't say it when trump did two
coveted relief bills but then they did
say it when joe biden did his
and it really hasn't happened it really
hasn't happened and
um as sort of like a frame of reference
i guess i would say
a lot of people wonder why
is there a target of two percent
inflation like why wouldn't you target
zero inflation
isn't it better for prices not to go up
um
this is a big macroeconomic topic but
the very general gist of this
is if people expect prices to remain the
same
or to go down they would delay purchases
if you believed that a car would be
cheaper in a year than today
you would potentially delay buying that
car until next year because you expect
it to be cheaper
people delaying purchases
reduces business income businesses then
start laying people off
those people then have less money with
which to make purchases and you create a
deflationary spiral this is like basic
economics okay this is
the idea so that's why you target
a little bit of inflation that inflation
is where economic growth essentially
comes from that inflation is the
incentive to buy something today rather
than six months from now the idea that
i can get it today for less and i can
start using it so that's
this is a very very uh general
explanation of why there is
an inflation target that is something
above zero
we'll talk more about this tomorrow okay
so that's the latest on uh
on the inflation um numbers
uh i do want to say thank you to
um no one actually oh sorry okay no i
thought i had somebody to thank but i
actually don't
okay uh do oh sorry hold on super chat
super chat super chats let me see what
we've got here
what's your opinion on india's covid
policy i don't know what their coveted
policy is
i mean i've been following the numbers
the cases have started to come down
a little bit but i've not been uh i've
not oh hold on where is that
there it is i've not been following it
um caleb says love you pac-man everyone
has flaws kalinsky
is painfully class reductionist sam
cedar is very slow talker you were
definitely deafeningly quiet on
israel oh yeah i we talked about it on
the bonus show today
um this is not really a foreign policy
show and whenever i talk about foreign
foreign policy uh nobody cares it gets
no traffic
um just people get mad when they
disagree with me and
it gets no traffic you know these these
videos get eight thousand nine thousand
views on youtube
um and so i just you know it's the same
thing as every two years this is the
exact same thing that happens
hamas fires rockets israel reacts
disproportionately
uh you know people are married to their
ideas of this is only a problem
uh of big bad israel or this is only a
problem of hamas
um and i comment on it and i just get
angry
emails that i'm not enough on one side
or the other and it gets no views
and then things get quiet for two years
and then the exact same thing happens
again so there's just nothing new to say
every two years this happens every two
years everybody comes out with their
predetermined views
there's almost no no nuanced thinking on
it
um and but what my analysis is the same
as two years ago as four years ago
nothing will change as long as netanyahu
is in power which hopefully will change
soon nothing will change for as long as
hamas controls gaza and for as long as
hamas and the palestinian authority
can't get on the same page about what
they would like which is not going to
happen anytime soon
nothing will change and so um
you know deafeningly quiet we talked
about it on the bonus show today
and um my audience just doesn't
really you know it's not a big foreign
policy in general has never been a big
topic on this show
so that's the uh that's the gist of it
there's really i mean
people seem to want something more and
the other thing i think is important to
mention is
whenever i've had a situation on the
show where people demand i address
something um it almost
never is of interest to a large portion
of the audience
and i can do no right on it either where
if i don't talk about it it's a problem
and if i talk about it and have any
opinion other than the one that the
people demanding i talk about it have
it's also a problem it's just sort of
like i think people looking to
um essentially try to like cancel
cancel me either way either because i
didn't talk about it or i said the wrong
thing
i would say just cancel me you know just
just go ahead and do it um but we have
so many other things to
talk about and and we will do that
robert brunswick says hey david love
your show
thank you rand was equating gain of
function which is trying to make viruses
more powerful with other types of virus
research like identification
fauci says the nih did not fund gain of
function research yes
that is absolutely true let's even look
at some of those clips
because we have them uh let's just jump
right into it think about that for a
moment
the sars virus had a 15 mortality
we're fighting a pandemic that has about
a one percent mortality can you imagine
if a sars virus can you imagine juiced
up
and had viral proteins the virus is
juicing
added to it to the spike protein if that
were released accidentally
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect that the
nih has not ever and does not now
right fund gain of function research
in the wuhan institute the virus
dr barrett does not doing gain to
function research and if
i think also dr barrack was doing some
stuff on sars kobe 1.
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted in north
carolina i don't think concerning a bad
virus spike protein that he got from the
wuhan institute into the sars viruses
gain of function
that is not a minority because at least
200
scientists have signed a statement from
the cambridge working group
saying that it is gain of function well
it is not
and if you look at the grant and you
look at the progress reports
it is not gain a function despite the
fact
that people tweet that so you're trying
to support sending money to the wuhan
virology institute
we do not send money now did you miss
the conversation
money we did under your tutelage we were
sending it through eco health it was a
sales agency and a subgrant do you
support
the money from nih that was going to the
wuhan institute
let me explain to you why that was done
the saws cov1 originated
like i said in china it would have been
irresponsible
of us if we did not investigate
the bat viruses and the civil war so
sars kovi one was being was being
studied
uh years ago in china and it doesn't
really fit
rand paul's conspiracy uh let's listen
to one more cl i have a full clip on
this so i won't do all of these but it
is interesting
absolutely possible to send it to the
chinese government that we may not be
able to trust with this
uh knowledge and with this uh incredibly
dangerous viruses
scientists like yourself who favor gain
of function really i don't
favor again again it's like fauci
doesn't even have to be there because
rand's questions
are not responsive to what fauci says
fauci addressed gain of function twice
and ran just continues
that are not correct government
defenders of gain of function
such as yourself it's it's a
it's a parody of itself all right so
we're going to get away from that
because it's just it's just nonsense
um okay oh whoa hold on that out of
nowhere
yeah if you're just joining us i've
committed to doing uh i i would do a
stream wearing absolutely no
socks maybe even no pants although it
wouldn't be on screen
if and when my twitter gets to 200 000
followers which may which may happen
today
as we stand by for joe biden okay let me
get into some of these new voicemails
that i have
oh hold on a second i do want to say
thank you to
blake misquida blake misquita
just signed up for a membership on my
website thank you blake
and if we do get to 100 i'll open up the
phone lines right now
don't make me do it because i will do it
and i want to say thanks to blake for
that
also thanks to technicolored liquid
imp um
and dave schmidt as well as milo wilde
for the twitch subs by the way listen if
you have an amazon prime account
and you're not doing a twitch prime sub
it doesn't even have to be for my
channel it should be
that'd be the best but it doesn't have
to if you're not using your twitch prime
sub every month that you get from amazon
as a prime member
you're leaving five dollars in jeff
bezos his pocket that you could give to
a streamer that you watch
okay so just give it make sure you're
using it every month and remember it
doesn't renew automatically
uh it's crazy to leave imagine jeff
bezos is saying to every single one of
you
if you want to take five bucks from me
and give it to somebody like the david
pakman or whoever you can
or leave it in my pocket if you don't
use that twitch prime sub you're saying
bezos keep the money can you even
imagine that it's nuts
okay let's get into some of the
voicemails
there's an anti-vaxx guy who has called
a few times now um
he is coming up with just insane stuff
let's listen to that
hey dave it's eric from mass again i
just wanted to let you know that uh
more people have died from the vaccine
more people
who died from the vaccine what in the
past four months
the covered vaccines that have died from
vaccines in the last 20 years combined
you can check that you can look it up
i did couldn't find it i'm sure you'll
have some falsity or whatever
i found a falsity exactly that's what
happened but uh
all i can say is uh you you must have
great lawyers
right i've given you all this
information and you still keep touting
these fake all of the information
from eric from mass and yet i still
think the vaccines work
crazy right ass vaccines that are
killing entering people
i mean your legal team is probably going
to be busy for months after this
i love that yeah legal team they're
they're really busy they're loving it
i mean that's really something huh let
me know how that goes
i will thank you i will let you know of
any uh legal legal elements
that are problematic thanks to uh oh a
lot
massive dump of twitch subs jmc smith
handsome anchor
sluggo owen level two me
beef stews as well as fez tiggs
german's cousin x have all grabbed
twitch subs putting us at 17.
um let me go to
a couple of other new characters okay so
that's the vaccine death sky
we've gotten that out of the way next
is this is just marked failed
troll call that's an interesting title
let's see if we can figure out what that
is
fail troll call hi david no one cares
about you
oh boy
all right i guess they were about to own
me but they
but something something happened uh
thanks to junk saint as well as
cheesehead
for the twitch subs appreciate that guys
um
all right so that's failed troll call
and then here's another one marked
furious with discord this is someone
that i guess hates discord let's see
i find discord useless
oh boy whenever i put a comment
on there if somebody doesn't like it
they put a whole bunch of spam and
nonsense
after it
i'm attacked for just saying
cryptocurrency should should be illegal
it's being used for money laundering
it's using news for blackmail being used
to rip off governments
education systems hospitals right
it's destroyed an energy network in
georgia just now
and i'm attacked i don't know maybe i'm
too old for this childish discord i'm 50
55 years old okay and i just uh
it's just annoying i don't know
i just i i i caught you you know what's
mostly used for money laundering
us dollars a lot of um you have a lot of
uh trolls or whatever on discord
i don't know i thought it was for yours
for your service for your
for your members this guy seems
depressed he's bumming me out i'm not
gonna lie
i'm like super bummed out about my
entire show
based on this guy maybe you're into
cryptocurrency i hold some yeah we've
gone far
without cryptocurrency it's a bunch of
[ __ ]
all right and your your your
your platform you know your videos are
great they attract people
we join memberships and then beyond that
it's a bunch of big [ __ ] joke well
you know big [ __ ] joke
depressing have a good one yeah that's
not a boomer that's a doomer
it's just depressing i actually think i
might have
um i might have another jimmy from
philly message also furious about the
discord i'm gonna check that out in a
moment
uh i do want to say thanks to buster man
as well as logic
plc dude and hippie chick blazing condor
who have signed up via twitch
cheese had just dumped five gifted subs
putting us at 10.
bowflex man is 11. junk saint is 12.
cheesehead himself is 13.
putting us at 32
which i very much appreciate and the
secret unpublished coupon code
immoral 21 is still live let me see if i
can find the jimmy thing here hold on
because jimmy also was just off the
rails about
discord um a few other super chats
pair says what's the difference oh you
know what let me see if i can fix this
hold on a second
because we really need i think we want
to keep
it this way yeah there we go pair says
what's the difference between an
anti-vaxxer and an anti-vaxxer joke
the joke never gets too old
isn't it the anti-vaxxer never gets too
old because they die because they're not
vaccinated i think that i think you
reversed it pair
um kirik says hope you're doing well
what's the
ratio of subscribers to non-subscribers
watching the streams
i have no idea i really don't know
dev says how is your hair so perfect all
the time i don't know
yeah i'm not sure um
cpi will likely be above average for a
few months because of comparisons to
last year and the semiconductor shortage
nothing to worry about yet i
completely agree with you totally agree
um
okay hold on all right so now we've got
here it is okay here's jimmy's from
philly
dropping a brutal attack on all methods
of contact
david give me some philly [ __ ] the
contact form why have you made it so
difficult to contact you
i went on to discord it's it's [ __ ]
chinese and written things
why do you make it to you why have you
made it difficult for people
the point is to make it just difficult
enough for jimmy not to be able to do it
but
easy enough for like normal people
to contact you a simple [ __ ] phone
number it's all that's required
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm i'm done okay and
then he called back multiple more times
um
okay i think that's it as far as jimmy
goes
um yeah okay
i don't have anything else on jimmy but
that's that
uh all right thanks to slow speed chase
as well as agent ray
for the twitch subs very much appreciate
that numbers 33
and 34 and also a
huge thank you to toby tropper
toby just went to join pacman.com
used the code immoral 21 and
dropped a bomb of a membership on us
toby tropper
at join pakman appreciate that okay
update on deaths as well as oh wait a
second
country u.s deaths and cases
things are continuing to go in the right
direction my friends
okay uh we have now a
further decline in cases we had this
little
we had this big decline and then uh oh
oh wait but then it went down and then
oh no it's back up
we are now accelerating down and are
below 40 000 cases a day for the first
time
since when was it below 40
000 a day since
september we have not seen that that is
excellent news
as far as deaths go
we are now down to 6 35 a day it's still
nothing to cheer about but that's the
lowest it has been
since let's see 6 35 it's been a long
time
it's been about since j it's been it's
been wow
10 months since we've been this low as
far as deaths go
so that's great and then in terms of
vaccination
we got to this point right around april
12th april 13th
april 10th where really supply
started to exceed demand people who
really wanted the vaccine had gotten it
and then it started to slow down and we
have seen declining vaccination
for almost a full month it's now
climbing again
and with the authorization of the pfizer
vaccine for 12 to 15 year olds
yesterday i believe it was we now are
having a
uh we are now seeing a resurgence of
vaccination i think things will look
really good by by memorial day
i see people saying what about july 4th
i don't think july 4th is going to see a
surge
and the reason why is july 4th is mostly
an outdoor
event almost no one is getting this
outdoors
before anyone was vaccinated the
estimates are that one out of a thousand
cases were being
transmitted outdoors that's before
vaccination
and that was people doing really stupid
stuff um
now with 34 of the country fully
vaccinated by the fourth of july it'll
probably be
if we do half a percent a day 60. we'll
probably be beyond 50
fully vaccinated by the fourth the we're
not going to see a fourth of july uh
search
i just don't see it so this is really
good we really i know that there's some
people who are
uh sort of like dependent on the doom
and gloom
the doomers i have been i was a doomer
when that was what was warranted
uh this is going to continue improving
and things are going to be looking very
good by the fourth
fourth of july i i'm extremely confident
in that
uh okay let's see here
i want to say thank you to alice
marevias smurfs and big juts for the
subscriptions
i wonder if big juts is my friend big
juts justin
that's interesting see if we can figure
that out that's that's an
i don't know if i can right now oh i
might cause my entire system to freeze
we don't want that
yeah let me get away from that but
that's interesting um
do i still have a garden yeah i'm gonna
do a garden
tour soon i made a really strong
announcement last week that i've got
two types of tomatoes three types of
peppers
japanese eggplant um
what else do i have purple basil and
thai basil
my strawberry bush is into year two
uh two types of lettuce i've got swiss
chard
four green pea plants what else do i
have
um it's a nice looking garden this year
and i'll do i'll do a tour pretty soon
in fact i'd com
not i would even do this if we get to a
hundred members today
i will not only open the phone lines i
will do a uh
i will do a garden tour as well okay
very very
strong announcement i want to say thanks
to color orgy
k canuck and coldstone the gamer
all for signing up today via twitch that
puts us at 41.
um the japanese eggplant is not looking
great yeah
people are most curious about the
japanese eggplant i'm expecting
zero fruit thanks to joe who says love
the channel keep doing you
also thank you joe also when i say thank
you to carlos madrid
carlos just went to join pacman.com and
grabbed
a membership carlos you are a uh
a great person i very much appreciate
that
uh we are standing by for joe biden and
um we will
uh hear from him about vaccines
momentarily scheduled for five minutes
ago
you know he's always running a little
bit late oh
check in on your twitter let me see
we're getting there we're getting there
yeah i'm very close we are dangerously
close to me hitting 200 000 subscribers
our followers on
uh twitter i have promised to do an
entire show
without wearing any pants if we get to
two hundred thousand
it's irrelevant because you only see me
from the waist up
all right but uh it is a promise that i
made
so that's exciting stuff a big thank you
to odw for gifting 22
subs also thanks to tm hart
with the sub that puts us at 65
and i'm yeah i'm hoping for joe biden
with the sunglasses
as well jabba says where's the marimekko
mug us finns miss it i wish i knew what
that is i don't know what that is
um daniel says easel aid
ease man
i wish i knew what that was about i just
don't know what that means
i genuinely have no clue what that means
easel aid easement i hope it's not
racist
um some people asking me to talk to
destiny i would consider doing that
we've not checked in for a long time
um i would consider doing that
people get angry though half the people
like the destiny stuff have people get
furious
um yeah i don't know every time i talk
to destiny half the audience comes to me
and says sir
never do that again but the other half
likes it thanks also to alan carter
who just signed up on my website alan is
new member number 66 today thanks alan
that's uh very generous of you and i
appreciate that
uh you haven't missed it no joe biden's
just running late
he's just running late and of course the
trumpists are here see this this is the
new
resistance let me see if i can move this
uh can i show this to you
i don't know if i can no anyway if you
look at this stream right now
there's 1200 dislikes for the biden
stream
that's what trumpists have been
relegated to in order to uh
resist biden they just dislike the live
streams as if that you know who cares
um and then they say who could trust the
polls i mean look at all those dislikes
on youtube it's crazy
but that's what they're doing a big
thank you also to
sweet thang and syndiceratist
for the twitch subs very much appreciate
that putting us at 68.
um my expectation is that the
announcement from joe biden
will relate to the approval of the
vaccine for 12 to 15 year olds
uh tell me if you if you disagree but
that's my that's my expectation on that
uh okay so we've gotten that done
oh i did have yeah i don't even know if
i want to do this
there's another voicemail
i just i'm going back and forth about
this not because i think this person
is mentally ill but because
i think it's important to understand
when there are really
delusional unhinged political beliefs
but at the same time you don't
necessarily want to give people ideas
uh i don't even i i don't even know that
i want to say more there there was a
very interesting voicemail that i was
thinking of playing for you guys but i
just don't
let me just review the transcript and
see if i'm comfortable with it
uh hold on where is it even
i don't know that i was planning to do
this but
yeah i think i wanna i wanna think about
it a little i'm not gonna do it right
now
i wanna think about it a little more
yeah some people are demanding i play it
i'm not like vague
teasing vague stuff i really i really
don't mean to it's just
it's so weaponized and i know that
there's different views among my
audience
about publicizing some of the most vile
weaponized stuff
this one is just so disgusting that i
really i just want to give it a little
bit more thought
i apologize um
yes i'm being accountable to my content
that's exactly right
that's exactly that's exactly what i'm
doing okay
um share the transcript maybe let me put
it this way the transcript contains the
word cuck i don't know if that
makes people lean towards the play it or
or towards the not play it
the transcript doesn't really do justice
to the full thing
uh let's just get away i'll think about
it i'll think about it okay
um i do want to thank a couple of other
people cam
finney just grabbed a subscription on my
website
thank you cam you are a great american
to quote the great sean hannity
also thanks to oh how do you pronounce
this mexican i believe it's a mayan
name x-o-c-h-i-t-l
i never know how to pronounce that
let me see if i can find it
pronunciation
i want to make sure i get it right
let's see here soju so chilled that
doesn't sound right to me is that right
oh people are saying it is okay thank
you to social cantu
for the membership uh at joinpakman.com
new members 69 and 70 today
both taking advantage of the coupon code
immoral 21.
i guess it let me listen to that one
more time socio
so chill so chill okay
if that's what it is that's what it is i
uh i want to get the right pronunciation
that's my priority
so it's like so chill but so chill yeah
i like that name actually that that's a
i could it's a strong name i have no
problem with it
um a lot of people saying
oh in arizona it's a common name
interesting all right so chill canto i
appreciate the subscription um oh we
should i guess say something about
the uh we should say something about the
fuel situation right
um people have been asking about the gas
shortages i saw a woman
see if i can actually find that i saw an
image
of a woman filling a plastic bag with
gasoline
which unless mechanical physics and and
fluid dynamics work differently than i
understand
it seems like not the best way to get
extra gasoline
but there are now uh we are seeing gas
prices creep up and there are also some
shortages in the southeast of the united
states
let me see if i can find this gasoline
plastic bag
i've really never seen anything like it
um
people have been using bags for gas for
years i'm not aware of that
let's see if i can just find the picture
yeah from what i've read i'm expecting
the supply issue to be resolved by the
end of the uh
by the end of the weekend oh the video
is from 2019
okay
yeah it's being promoted as if it's a
new oh a lot of people i guess put
just get a plastic trash bag and put
gasoline in it
yeah i mean it strikes me as uh
i don't know what can i even say it
doesn't seem super safe
and uh it doesn't seem like an approved
container but from what i'm reading
that supply issue should be resolved by
the end of the weekend and i certainly
hope that's the case
by the way i did a little thing today
for um we did a story today on the
podcast i don't know if you guys saw
that some of the new york city mayoral
candidates
were asked during a new york times
editorial board meeting what do you
think is the median home price in
brooklyn
now when i was last in brooklyn before i
went to a different
neighborhood um about six years ago
five years ago no wait hold on two five
yeah six almost six years ago
um if you had asked me what's the median
brooklyn home price i would have said
550 000 at the time
so now you know i now know it's about
900 000 but if you had asked me
yesterday i probably would have said
somewhere between 800 000 and a million
or something like that
two people said um
two candidates said they one guy's like
a hedge fund guy and the other guy or a
citigroup guy the other guy don't
believe what he does what he did
said they thought the median home price
in brooklyn was like 90 grand one of
them said 80 to 90 grand the other said
100 grand
so my initial reaction was like how
could you possibly be this out of touch
how could how
how could that possibly be the median
home price in brooklyn when there
are that's like one of the most in
demand places in the in the united
states
and uh and there's you know rural parts
of the country
where your average home is 125 150 175
000. so um i kind of like did a
self-test
can i identify the prices for different
things now i started with gas prices
i guess three dollars but i really have
no idea where gas prices are because
i've had an electric car
uh for for a long time and it turn where
are my notes here
um
and it turns out gas is is at 3.008
right now
it was completely random but somehow i
got that right so i was like okay i'm
still i'm still in touch with that
um the miami real estate market it's a
market i'm tangentially involved in but
don't know that much about what's the
median home price in miami
i guess 350 the real number is 398. so
i'm like sort of in touch
then i did milk and eggs milk and eggs
is tough because
after reading michael pollan's book uh
books i decided um
i'm gonna get like the hipster fancy
milk and eggs because the difference is
only a couple bucks and i'm not
consuming so much that it's gonna affect
my budget
and um so i get like you know these
pasture
raised what the hell you know crazy
crazy stuff uh that are like
six bucks a dozen but my guess on a on a
gal
and a dozen eggs was three dollars and
it's 266 so it's like i was in the i was
in the market
uh in in the ballpark and then for milk
i guess that organic milk is five bucks
a gallon i never even buy the gallon
because i don't drink that much
and it's actually four dollars so like
that's kind of close and then lastly i
looked at do i know what a loaf of bread
costs
bread's tough because you've got
everything from like subsidized
enriched white bread that you get like
you know factory bread all the way up to
you know ten dollar loaves at some hip
hipster bakeries
so i said i think the average loaf is
three
and the official rate is 250.
so my takeaway was that those mayoral
candidates
are something is very wrong like if i
see oh
this this person wants to be mayor and
they
think that the average home costs a
hundred grand and it really
costs 900 grand to me that would make me
question whether they have any idea what
the average person is
like sort of dealing with and
experiencing in new york city you tell
me if you disagree but if you're if you
have such a
misunderstanding of what something is
fundamental to life as housing costs
i would question whether you really even
understand the issues the city is facing
what do people think
agree agree
most people seem to agree what's going
on here
there seems to be closed captioning
coming in but we're not even seeing or
hearing anything yet
well we must be getting close yeah
people see
insaniam girl who says this reminds me
of bill gates on ellen
i mentioned that in the segment there
was this segment where bill gates went
on the ellen degeneres show
and she said bill what do you think
these frozen
like pizza bites cost and i think he
said either 10 or 20 dollars
and it's like you know if a little thing
of pizza bites cost
20 life is even more
unaffordable than it is for many people
what is going on here getting some
strange
noises we should be getting close uh
yeah but look i'm not gonna play it
because i think the ellen degeneres show
is very aggressive with copyright
but um yeah it's like no if pizza bites
are 20 bucks then it's not it's not
gonna work for a lot of people
um when is biden live i think now
we're standing by okay
other super chats borah rudd says it's
mostly russian troll farms leaving
dislikes on biden videos okay
amy says amy
amy show sheet says that the
nahuatl way to pronounce is show sheet
a me show sheet okay welcome amy amy
very much appreciate that would i ever
do a podcast with jordan
clepper sure what's your favorite flavor
and brand of sparkling water
i don't but i don't know no no no no i
do uh
i make my sparkling water at home and
uh no uh i do plain completely plain and
i really just prefer
iced um
still water i don't know if at this
point that's considered edgy or not
i make it yeah i make it out of thin air
you should see the things i've got going
on at home i do want to say thank you to
maria
m for signing up at joinpackman.com with
the immoral 21 coupon code
thanks to aries osiris for signing up
also using that code and thanks to
gabriele
testore for signing up on my website
with the coupon code
immoral 21 putting us at 73.
um i think i missed
some twitch subs let me say thank you
to dream shannon lin the notorious
mr gory shayna joe
skillage smuggy fusty
bushy baby ryan the grumpy gay
to luanne sam s to ecky
sweet oh no sweet thing i already
thanked okay that's nine
putting us at 82.
yeah some pretty strong names oh yeah by
the way you know i've read about this
thing about
oh you know drinking ice water is bad
it's bad for this
it's bad for that you know it can cause
if you're if you're all hot
and you drink ice water you could
spontaneously combust
i've been able to find no evidence of
that and i love
ice water ice what that's one of the
toughest things for me when i go to
europe
and they give you um like
room temperature water even
in summer not for me
yeah if drinking ice water is wrong i
don't want to be right that's exactly
right
i want heavy ice heavy heavy ice
um okay let's check in on what's going
oh we are very close
we may actually do it i've committed to
doing a stream with no pants
if i get to 200 000 twitter followers we
are only
um 88 away we are down to our last 88
twitter followers before 200 000 and
then i will be doing a stream
full stream with no pants on you don't
see below my waist anyway so i don't
know why it's getting people all
excited but i am committed to doing it
and uh it looks look at that look at
those numbers
ice water burns more calories
what's the logic of that that ice water
it's more different than body
temperature so the body has to
consume more energy getting you into
equilibrium with the ice is that is that
the
the idea
because it's so cold that's not bad i
like that i'll take that
um wow look at this
what will happen first biden speaks or
we get to 200 000 on twitter
i think it's going to be a race to the
finish
yeah that's the logic i think but some
people will i don't remember if it's
work out or just walk around with like a
cooled vest
and i think the idea is your body has to
work to maintain body temperature
even though you're wearing because of
the cold vest your body has to warm
something like i think it's the same
gist as that
look at this
wow this is happening pretty strongly
yeah bathtub stream at 250k exactly
wow usually when we do something like
this when we get very close
uh people start unfollowing to be cute
which is fine i think this is going to
time out exactly with biden
and there it is ladies and gentlemen
what a moment
what a moment you know in the future
when you were asked where were you
when we did it you might remember and
you might not
stunning yep no that's very very strong
we did it
look at that it's going wild
i think it's probably cooling off man
biden is late huh
it's something else and now people are
unfollowing to try to get us back below
i think we can stop counting the ballots
right now
yeah huge dumps of twitter followers
so drinking an entire cup of ice water
only burns 10 calories relative to room
temperature
okay that doesn't seem like that much
this is considered fraud or actually
fraud
i would say okay very good
all right standing by for joe let's get
back to more serious things like telling
you
some oh actually no but this this
actually is something real that i wanted
to look at
let me see how i can do this i want to
show you just to give you guys a sense
i wanted to put up a hate mail but i
need to protect
the
i wanted to protect the identity of the
person
sending it maybe i could just paste it
into
a notepad is that an appropriate way to
show you hate mail
let me see if i can do that um
i just want to give you guys a sense of
the stuff i get daily so this is
matthew okay let me see if i can now
bring it on here
here it is okay check this out this is
just a sampling of the stuff i get
matthew wrote to me hey i got a great
idea
i'm a conservative supporter of trump
and you would be hard-pressed to find
anyone more loyal than me
so why don't you interview me the next
time you want to give
you want to use just one person's
remarks in a ridiculously
weak attempt to give perspective on what
all
conservative and or trump supporters
think feel believe what's more
ridiculous using just one person
or using a 70 year old senile crackpot
who looked as if she could be biden's
long-lost soulmate
do you really believe that one person
really viewed that
and believed that mrs long lost biden
speaks for all 75 million
i don't know what this person's talking
about if you do god help you
if you don't and still for some reason
produce this garbage
then once again god help you you take
the cake buddy
there is a new number one when we want
to have a good laugh
at the loony left not that we think you
speak for all
that be stupid what are they talking
about
what on earth is this person talking
about
um here's this is like
just a couple days worth okay here's
another one
um this is barry
barry says take your [ __ ] ass
back to argentina don't come to this
country
talking your libtard nonsense f off
okay um
[Music]
let me give you another one here
this is like special this next one is
special this is literally from
karen okay now
you would think this was from like
november when trump was still president
it's not it's from three days ago
okay karen wrote to me and said stop
bashing our president mr trump
what you do know china
flipped votes within their dominion
voting machines right
what oh wait your show is based on
opinion and not
facts wait until the truth keeps coming
out
and states prove the election was rigged
i am waiting karen i am waiting
you're going to be looking for another
job unless you change your tune
that's another funny one you're going to
be looking for another job
i don't know that people really
understand sort of like
how my industry works nobody can really
fire me like youtube could say we banned
you
facebook could say we banned you every
one of you could cancel
your memberships or whatever but what
does that mean looking for another job
trump stands for freedom in america and
wants to keep our freedoms
do you even know what was on that
evergreen ship
now it wasn't called evergreen was it
was that ship this relates to that ship
stuck in the channel do you guys
remember what that ship was called i
don't think it was ever green even
wasn't it ever something else ever given
ever given that's what it was yeah
evergreen ship of course not because
you're
not in the military and know the facts
now
i didn't think that that ship even had
anything to do with the military wasn't
it like
you know sort of like a merchant marine
uh what does it have to do with the
military
okay we as americans are lucky to have
trump because he's keeping our freedoms
he hasn't been president for months you
can't even go on facebook which
zuckerberg paid millions to government
officials all around the country to
cover up the election
truth and he has ties to china that's
like an aside
or twitter etc and say dominion or
vaccine or election or biden
that's taking away our free speech you
[ __ ] report that
this is a this is a really sick person
gag grow up research the facts oh wait
you're from the age of not researching
because it's easier
you better kiss trump's ass pretty soon
when he comes back
because he's saving your ass from
communism
because it's here already so in the same
email
they said our president mr trump
but then they also said when trump comes
back
and communism is here already
why would he come back if he's president
ever look up
look into bill gates and why he's buying
up so much land lately
look him up in the evergreen ship and
you will see
what good people we have left in this
country just saved us from the next
pandemic you [ __ ]
okay everybody got that you do know no
one is or has been since jan 20th in the
white house right
of course you don't you naive [ __ ]
you suck you should be ashamed as an
american because you don't know half the
stuff going on behind the scenes
now here's something really funny
this person who wrote under the name
karen
this person has been emailing me under
the name chris
for a really long time and under the
name susan
how do i know uh
because of the writing pattern okay so
this
is supposedly susan
all right check this out this email is
from karen
this next one is from susan it's the
same person
same person they also write to me under
the name chris susan
you're the propagandist dude your
instinct
listen to the interview dude that's your
genuine problem highest tally of
migrants since feb 20 2006.
you might want to listen to the
interview again davey there's big money
in immigration law
david leopold is really coloring your
so-called intelligent premise
listen to the interview again davey what
interview
jojo is bringing in kovid child
trafficking people who need to be
sheltered at great cost
criminal elements most importantly so
many children have come to the us
unaccompanied except for their handlers
and that's my fact she seems drunk again
come on man
your hate is showing so this time it's
the opposite right
uh and then let me find
the chris one
hold on where is that chris
now i'm having trouble finding the chris
one hold on
the chris one is uh it's really
something else
oh here we go okay
so this is this is the same person now
this is chris
and and we have ip addresses we know
these are the same people okay
this is chris you little turd
trump's speech was a desperate plea for
mercy you're full of [ __ ] as usual
hey [ __ ] why don't you post the
actual words or video trump spoke to
incite the so-called riot
you won't because he never said anything
to incite anyone
do you want me to post the video of mad
maxine waters inciting the people to get
in the faces of people at the grocery
store gasoline station
remember that i've got literally
hundreds of those types of leftist
incitement videos you got nothing
[ __ ]
you're part of the orwellian brainwashed
morons who play make-believe for power
just because your corrupt buddies in the
media have brainwashed the idiots of
america
that doesn't mean one word of the [ __ ]
is true
it's all fake news you are a bdi
little [ __ ] sincerely chris okay
anyway so
those three people um all who use
the same initial it's karen
chris and susan all with the same last
initial
all from the same uh uh ip address okay
so anyway some people spending a lot of
time
doing that very very focused on me
and they have been for a really long
time strange very strange
um david macon only fans and upload the
show where you're not wearing pants
yeah i don't know about that uh
well i don't even know what i don't even
know what only fans is to be perfectly
frank
big thank you to mano drizzle as well as
small fuzzy moss who just gifted five
subs
that's six thanks to remy bucky seven
dream
is eight i think that gets me caught up
that puts us at 90.
also big thank you
to christopher cullen who just signed up
at
joinpackman.com chris thank you
thank you so much chris i really
appreciate that
um is bdi de [ __ ] anti-semitic i
don't know
i really i you know that crossed my mind
is there a
uh is there some is beta-eyed
is that possibly anti-semitic it
crossed my mind but i don't really know
i don't know what people think about
beady-eyed
possibly no
not really probably not nothing comes to
mind
yeah it may not be that's why i didn't
mention it bd-eyed
let's see anti-semitic let's see if
there's anything here
nah i'm not seeing that
neo-nazis like to say sleepy eyes
for identifying jews
yeah i think i think sleepy eyes i know
the history of that
bdi's it doesn't doesn't seem to me
yep somebody disagrees you can let me
know but i just don't
i'm not aware of anything like that yeah
all right very good uh okay let's see
here you skipped a bunch of super chats
including mine
i'm sorry let me start working on them
some people are saying liz was about to
release the gop healthcare plan and
that's why she was removed by the deep
state yeah i assume that's a joke
hate mail without anti-semitism
respectful idiocy
your green floral mug marimekko big
finish brand oh that's right i do have
those mugs
yeah that's right that's right karen
thinks you can get fired and replaced by
another david pakman
ps let us know your thoughts on
israel-palestine we won't bite on the
bonus show today
and addressed earlier in this stream
um people in general seem to think
you're fully vaccinated means you can't
catch the virus
deep dive on how on vaccines and how
they work we have a deep dive already
on the uh on the youtube channel on
vaccines you can find it
um if you are felt fully vaccinated you
can catch the virus your odds are
dramatically reduced
uh to the point where it is uh
like other things that if you are
willing to be out in the world you could
catch
that's the important thing and yes i am
vaccinated
mikel says just take your pants off now
yeah i don't think so
jesus leone says in light of the gas
shortage do you think trump will talk
about it and mention russia
my bet is he talks about flushing
toilets uh
i have no idea yeah it's possible trump
will talk about it
on his blog actually i kind of want to
see
has trump donald j trump.com
desk let's see what trump has blogged
about
here's some trump blogs i see that
everybody
is comparing joe biden to jimmy carter
it would seem to me that is very
unfair to jimmy carter jimmy mishandled
crisis after crisis
but biden created crisis after crisis
first there was the biden border crisis
yeah that's that's the one nobody cared
about under trump
then the biden economic crisis economy
is doing well the biden israel crisis
has nothing to do with biden now the
biden gas crisis has nothing to do with
biden
joe biden has had the worst start of any
president in u.s history
that's funny because joe biden's
approval just hit 63 percent
bizarre that was an hour ago
trump then trump's using this like
twitter basically
trump just kind of like reblogging sean
hannity
then this morning trump saying liz
cheney's a bitter horrible human being i
watched her yesterday and realized how
bad she is with the republic for the
republican party
she has no personality or anything good
yeah he's using this like twitter
she's a talking point for democrats
whether that means the border gas lines
inflation or destroying our economy
she's a warmonger whose family
stupidly pushed us into the never-ending
middle east disaster draining our wealth
and depleting our great military the
worst decision in our country's history
i look forward soon to watching her as a
paid contributor to cnn
or msdnc wow trump is now doing like
five
plus of these a day all right well
whatever
he's sending out messages good for him
um
ryan says i'd like to hear more of your
thoughts on idealism and pragmatism
fighting for progressive policies and
dems capitulating for incremental
changes
okay yeah i mean i've talked about that
a lot but i would do more let's get
let's get a little more light here hold
on
see if i can pop this up a little
the lightest the light is changing all
right good
um julie van osdol says v-a-e-r-s is
where the vaccine death misinformation
is coming from it's basically a tip
line by the way eggplant grows itself
give it time
part sun okay
i hope that that's correct it's mostly
oh okay i got that one already good
um the division needs to end
cnn and msnbc have no indication of a
biden speech starting soon are you sure
this is happening
uh yeah i mean it says we'll begin
shortly
and it's it's on biden's
as far as i know let's check the biden
schedule
yet still on there for 3 30 which was 40
minutes ago
south court auditorium it's on the
schedule and it's the the white house is
live right now
okay uh thanks david your channel is
refreshing arthur says love the show
sorry you have to deal with crazy people
yeah
it is what it is it is what it is can't
do too much about it
uh just comes uh comes with the
territory i guess i would say
i do want to say thank you to
austin nay who just signed up on my
website joinedpakman.com
and his new member number 92 today
uh also thanks to r2 magnum kalinas
13th hour gordon z hall
african farmer fins fan
jean tarrage and liquid ice that's one
two three four
five six seven eight putting us at 100
on the dot nice all right so we'll open
some phone lines
momentarily it looks like this is about
to start
the uh cart ready
let's see i'll just move this down a bit
so we can see the uh there we go
this should be starting and then we'll
take a few phone calls
joe biden's being interviewed right now
on tv that doesn't make sense
i just don't think that that's the case
yeah it should be should be momentarily
but we will take some phone uh some
phone calls yeah
beautiful uh maybe i will even get that
queued up just so we're ready
i don't expect it to be a long statement
from joe biden
it's weird because the uh closed
captions seem to start
and then nothing happens it's strange
yeah i'm not sure but the white house
wouldn't be live if joe biden was not
about to speak ah here he is very good
good afternoon again
tomorrow uh we'll cross
250 million vaccine shots administered
shots since i took office i think it's a
pretty
consequential achievement for the nation
i promised i'd
keep you up to date every 50 million
shots today i have an important update
here we go last week i launched a new
phase of our vaccination program
at that time i set two new goals for our
country
the first was getting seventy percent of
adults
their first shot by july the fourth
the second was having 160 million
americans
of all ages fully vaccinated by that
same date
right i'm pleased report we've made
strong progress on the adult vaccination
efforts in just
the past few days by making it easier
than ever to get vaccinated
you can visit vaccine.gov
or text your zip code to 438829
to find a vaccination site near you
and we're also opened up thousands of
federal pharmacy sites
to vaccinations without appointment so
people can just walk up and get the shot
right now more employers than ever are
giving people time off as well
to get their shots more grocery and
retail stores and sports teams are
providing discounts and promotions to
encourage
customers and fans to get vaccinated
i was talked to a bunch of governors
yesterday
one of the governor of maine points out
that if you're a hunter or fisherman in
maine
and you want to get a license no problem
you don't have to pay for it if you get
your vaccination shot at the same time
you get your license
right point is there's a lot more
convenient places for people to get
their vaccine shot from may 24th to july
4th
uber and lyft and i think is incredibly
generous of them are going to offer
everyone in america free rides
to and from vaccinations i think that
will be taken advantage of to find out
where the vaccination site is call uber
lyft they will take you there wait for
you and take you back
as a result even though more than half
of the adults in the country have
already gotten their first shot
we have fewer people who need to be
vaccinated than ever before and we're
actually actually seeing a slight
increase
in the pace of vaccinations across the
past week
and we're now on track to hit 60 percent
of adults
with at least one shot by next week
we still have a lot of work to do to get
the adult vaccination rate to 70 percent
but i believe we're going to get there
so today i want to talk about an
exciting new development
when i spoke last week i said we're
hoping to soon add a new element for our
vaccination program
nice vaccinations for adolescents ages
12
and older and then on monday after
rigorous thorough review
the food and drug administration the fda
authorized pfizer vaccine
for use in that age category 12 and up
today an independent advisory committee
to the center for disease control and
prevention the cdc
voted to recommend it recommend its use
now pending the cdc's final
final approval later today we're going
to have for the first time a safe and
effective covet 19 vaccine
for adolescents over the 12 years of age
this is one more giant step on our fight
against the pandemic
i sincerely think the scientists
researchers and
clinical trial participants deserve our
thanks
they've all made this possible because
of them nearly 17 million more americans
are eligible to get vaccinated and
now now i encourage each of them and
their parents
to get their vaccination shots right
away and here's why
we know that kids at this at this age
12 and above are at risk from
covet 19. about 3 million covet 19 cases
have been reported in kids
under 17 years of age and teenagers can
spread it to their friends
to their siblings to their parents and
to their grandparents
true now that vaccine is authorized for
ages 12 and up
and i encourage their parents to make
sure they get the shot
as i promised last week we're ready
this new population is going to find the
vaccine roll out fast and efficient
as of tomorrow more than 15 000
pharmacies across this country will be
ready to vaccinate this age group
most of these pharmacies are close to
family as theirs
as a family home as the kids school is
to their family home
we're also going to be getting vaccines
to farm it for to
pediatricians and family doctors so
parents and children can talk to their
doctors who they trust
about getting the vaccination and
they'll be able to do it at that office
we're also partnering with school-based
clinics and community health centers
of course we remain focused on equity in
our vaccine program
the vaccine is free for everyone free
additionally if teens are on the move
this summer
they can get their first shot in one
place in a second shot elsewhere
at the same time we're also launching an
important public education campaign
first and foremost we're providing
families with trusted medical
information
they need to make informed decisions
about the vaccination
and the vaccine our medical and
scientific experts at cdc in the
national
institute of health will be out there in
the public every day to answer questions
and get the facts out we will also be
partnering with the health care
providers
schools community organizations states
and tribes and cities
right at the same time the bottom line
is this a vaccine for kids
between the ages of 12 and 15 are safe
effective easy fast and free
so my hope is that parents will take
advantage of the vaccine
and get their kids vaccinated and let's
remember
that millions of 16 and 17 year olds
have also been safely vaccinated
and as more and more americans get
vaccinated covet 19
hospitalizations and death rates
continue to fall love it
today the new york times reported the
number of covet hospitalizations in the
united states
since april of 2020
right after the start of this pandemic
it's the lowest
safe and effective vaccines are are
curbing the spread of the virus
and they're saving thousands of lives
and allowing millions of americans to
start returning
to a closer to normal life as i said
earlier
for everyone 12 years and up
it's never been easier or more
convenient to get vaccinated
visit vaccine.gov to find out where
or text your zip code to 438829 that is
438829. i like it in
three sections of two digits you'll find
the closest vaccine facilities to you
as that moment it's easy it's convenient
and it's free
so if you haven't gotten vaccinated or
still have questions
talk to someone you trust your physician
your pharmacist
your next door neighbor who got the shot
talk to your faith leaders
look at the folks in your community
who've gotten vaccinated
and are getting back to living their
lives your grandparents united with
grandkids friends getting together again
i've been saying for a long this for a
long time but i believe it
this is not a democratic or republican
issue to summit
this is about life and death it's about
getting us closer to
normal let me conclude with this
in light of the end of the uh that we've
been talking about
anti-vaxx bands happening right now in
the chat
and we need all of you to bring it home
americans ages 12 and up get vaccinated
and in july 4th let's celebrate our
independence as a nation
and our independence from this virus
right we can do this
as i said a little bit earlier today in
another context
you know i don't believe that the
american people there's any significant
portion american people who refuse to
get vaccinated you keep hearing about
how republicans won't and this look
if it's available if it's nearby if it's
convenient
people are getting vaccinated let's hope
i believe the vast majority of americans
are going to get vaccinated that's the
route we're going now
so may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops and if you've been
vaccinated
you don't have to wear this outside
around people
unless there's really large groups love
it you don't have to wear it
inside if you're with people that you uh
that have also been vaccinated
so uh protect yourself protect your
neighbors
thank you very much appreciate it
president what do you say to americans
who are worried about the supply of gas
at rising prices right now
we have been in very very close contact
with colonial
pipeline which is the one area you're
talking about where the
one of the reasons the gasoline prices
are going up
and i think you're going to hear some
good news in the next 24 hours
and i think we'll be getting that under
control
secondly i have
in the meantime made it easier for us to
have lifted some of the restrictions
on the transportation of fuel as well as
access
to the united states military providing
fuel and with vehicles to get it there
were
places where it's badly needed right and
um
i'd also point out that i think what
this shows is that uh
i think we have to make a
greater investment in education
as it relates to being able to
train and graduate more people
proficient in cyber security
and i've been saying for a long long
time now i know i probably
you could probably say it for me but i
think that
one of the most important things we have
to do by the way mods i'm ban hammering
anti-vaxx propaganda on both
twitch and youtube so let's let's keep
an eye out because it's getting really
bad
uh i have a better educated workforce
and that goes back to the days a long
time ago now or five years ago when i
was vice president and i
surveyed all the fortune 500 companies
said what do you most need
and remember what they said better
educated workforce
but they're not spending money to
educate the workforce
and but it's important that we do this
and the cyber security piece
is one i think you're going to see where
we need significantly
larger number of experts in the area of
cyber security
without a doubt for private companies as
well as
private companies being willing to
share data as to what how they're
protecting themselves
i think that's part of the long-term
answer not just in terms of
energy but across the board i know
that's not a direct response to your
question but it does impact on it i
think down the
the middle east and road you talk about
what conversations you have had
with officials there my
national security staff and defense
staff has been in constant contact with
their counterparts
in the middle east not just with the
israelis but also with
everyone from the egyptians of the
saudis to the emiratis etc
and i had a conversation with bibi
netanyahu
not too long ago i'll be putting out a
statement very shortly on that
my expectation and hope is that
this will be closing down sooner than
later
but uh israel has a right to defend
itself when you have thousands of
rockets flying into
your territory but uh i had a
conversation for a while with
with the prime minister of israel and uh
i think that
my hope is that we'll see this coming to
conclusions sooner than later
thank you all right joe biden taking a
couple of questions
you guys are bad i'm not supposed to be
answering all these questions i'm
supposed to leave but i
can't resist your questions um uh
i i came away uh encouraged
and but i want to make it clear to you
i'm encouraged not just because of
a solid meeting with
with the
republican leader in the house and with
uh
with mitch or whatever his name is
mcconnell who i've known a long long
time and worked with
i've been meeting with bipartisan
leaders
for a long time now i've met with
gosh knows how many i mean and there's
more than one
single group there's bipartisan organ
you know groups and made up of 10 to 20
members there's been groups that i i met
with uh
for example i met with yesterday with
kristen cinema i thought that was a
and she purported and i believe her to
speak for some of the bipartisan
her friends who are both sides of the
aisle about how to deal how to go
forward with infrastructure
so i'm generically i'm encouraged that
there is room to have a
compromise on a bipartisan bill that's
solid and significant
and a means by which to pay for it
without dropping
all of the uh
all the burden on on middle class and
working class people look
what's the one thing people are
concerned about with the gas
gasoline prices going up exactly right
and it matters if you make forty
thousand dollars a year
it matters if you're two family person
that make an eighty ninety thousand
dollar two
family two wage earners it matters
and what i don't want to do and this
will be another discussion we didn't get
into today
is how to pay for it and if everything
is paid for
by a user fee well then you know the
burden falls on working class folks
who are uh who are having trouble
they're we're we're getting them out of
the
they're coming around but it has this
has to be a burden shared
across the spectrum anyway thank you
guys americans be worried about
inflation sir
okay that one's gonna be the last one uh
so there goes joe biden with a very very
strong announcement
and we learned many many different
things there uh
let's now i'm gonna take your calls in a
moment
but let me first check in with uh
stephen kenneth destiny
benell the second people have been
demanding it and i want to see what's up
with him
uh the live twitter account is still
going and it's going pretty wild
uh let's see if we can get a hold of
stephen here
camera microphone
um let's see stephen
david can you hear me okay
i can hear you loud and clear can you
hear me okay are you live right now
i am in fact live right now oh okay are
you are you uh
are you home or what's going on well
yeah i am home indeed yeah
okay because you were in aruba briefly
right
um i was oh apparently you missed my
apparently you were
in aruba at the same time my fiancee was
i i think i
overlapped with uh molina destiny
bonnell the second by like a day but we
didn't know it
but i recommended a couple restaurants
to her and i think uh i think maybe she
went to a couple of them
maybe yeah the food that was actually
pretty good i'm not gonna lie
it's not anything like special local
really but it's just like there's some
good restaurants if you know where to go
have you ever been in cancun before i i
have i stopped going there when it just
became a little
too kind of spring breaky and touristy
for me
yeah i don't know if it's because i was
in a i tried for the first time to go to
like an all-inclusive resort
oh god would not recommend no
no no no no no yikes yeah i learned my
lesson on that one yeah you don't want
to do that no but no what any particular
place in aruba that uh
that you liked i don't remember i don't
[ __ ] i don't remember we stayed
near kind of like a lot of the um hotel
oh
hello restaurant
kind of like sorry hold on i just i just
missed what you said
are you talking about gianni's uh it
might have been called that
everybody takes a picture there at sun
down like literally like everybody lined
up to go like ask the staff to take
pictures of them and you're like um you
have to drive around kind of
um no i don't know what that is that
that's not ringing a bell to me no
okay just i mean oh my goodness and and
it's our connection today is
sort of uh very so-so
hello
oh man i'm here i'm here i'm here oh
are you okay yeah we're having i don't
know why we're having a connection issue
i have a pretty strong fiber connection
today so for once i don't think it's on
my end i don't know
oh wow
all um wow well i'm sorry to hear that
uh so what's what's new kind of in your
space
i guess um
in my space yeah really i don't think oh
are you focused more are you going back
towards gaming a little bit because of
the toxicity of the political
space or what's up um i always just kind
of just go back and forth and everything
you know how it goes
yeah just depends on what's going on and
are you in like a
horrible disagreement with anybody right
now that's become completely toxic
um not right now actually i think i'm
just kind of chilling
that's good and are you doing any debate
stuff or any in-person stuff
um i've done a few recently not in
person but
well actually wait no wait i went to um
kenosha to do like a debate panel thing
which was kind of interesting
i got into a little uh verbal fight with
um
jack posabic i don't know how you
pronounce that guy's name oh my goodness
it's like possobic or something like
that yeah man what an idiot
hey by the way oh speaking of which um
the richard wolf thing you know richard
wolf is my professor
in at umass a long long time ago oh my
god i'm so sorry for you but yeah um
did i felt like a lot of the debate was
a discussion
about what the debate was not about was
that
was that just my interpretation of it no
it kind of felt that way sometimes
yeah like i would check in and it would
be like here's 12
things that aren't feudalism here's 15
things that
aren't communism you know what i mean
yeah
um i it you know definitely got that
impression
for sure yeah do you think there was
like a clear
winner in that thing
um i mean it depends on how you quantify
winner like who looked the best
or who made the best arguments or who
was correct or
i guess what by what metric we have only
from a rhetorical point of view like
you know these debates are basically
performative rhetoric so i don't
you know i'm just saying like who do you
think came out looking the best
um i i mean people are gonna kiss me
being biased of course
but i would say definitely me is that
right
the reason why is i can usually tell
when people think i perform really well
because
everybody will be saying things like oh
this was a mistake oh you shouldn't have
done this oh blah blah and a lot of
people are getting mad at lance the surf
saying that it was irresponsible for
richard wolff to talk to me because it
was beneath them and blah blah generally
like if i'm reading a lot of comments
like that it's because they feel like
their guy did that but they don't want
to admit it so
jesus what a toxic space this is that's
just i don't even know what to pick
out to react to from that but this seems
just completely toxic
yeah welcome to the internet internet
politics wow
um all right well otherwise things are
and the whole like
you renting a streamer house that didn't
that fell through right
that was never gonna happen why would i
ever waste my time or money renting a
streamer house
no but there was a time when you and i
spoke on stream about how you were
looking at
getting some property and having
different streamers live there or
something
um oh well it's uh we'll say it's still
in the works okay
oh okay jeez this was on this wasn't
like a secret i mean this was on this
was on a live stream i don't know
oh yeah maybe okay so how's your how's
your
stream been today it's been solid we
just watched joe biden make an
announcement about uh
12 to 15 year olds can get can get the
vaccine you know
oh that's pretty cool yeah you're
vaccinated right um
uh i've got the first one coming soon
and was it did you have any side effects
or you were you were all good
uh no pretty easy i think maybe for the
second one people say sometimes
yeah no people they're talking well good
i mean i don't know that there's uh or
is there anybody on the left right now
that you are particularly enamored with
that you think is doing a good job
because usually you have a lot of
complaints
um i usually say you know what usually
when people ask for a recommendation say
you know deepak normally does
pretty decent job well other than me i'm
flattered by that but other than me
um in terms of large figures absolutely
[ __ ] not enough
but you know what is what it is any
elected official that you're liking
right now
any elected officials that i'm liking
right now um
i don't know everybody's fighting
recently over the stuff that's going on
recently i don't know if you guys have
covered any of that yeah um
yeah you know what here's a question
i have for you but i'm curious
so biden's strategy
seems to be one of like ultimate uh
collaboration right he desperately wants
republicans
republican senators to feel bought into
what he's doing
um something that i was kind of thinking
is the coronavirus stimulus
and then if this infrastructure thing
goes through a lot of americans are
probably going to come away having like
really positive feelings about these
things do you agree with that especially
the coroner's stimulus and everything
i do i mean it's popular yeah and so i
would correct the premise
just with one one thing i think joe
biden is committed
to the red to the talking about
bipartisanship
and offering republicans the ability to
participate but he did the covet
stimulus without a single one of them i
think he'll have to do
infrastructure without a single one of
them so i don't think he's convinced
that he
actually needs them well so
here's my question on that so what i
would have thought was
he tries to make everything work um
republicans won't come on board with
anything
and then when the coroner's stimulus
gets passed regardless he blows him up
he's like
well we passed it had a single
republican helped you know
yeah 2022 you guys figure out what you
want to do right to kind of like blow
him up but i noticed in his speeches
he's still giving credit to like
republican senators
i noticed that in one i
i was super confused i saw in a recent
session and i said i'm streaming the
exact same thing you said
because i was like wait why are you
giving them credit not a single one of
them [ __ ] voted like
a few people right a few people in my
chat
said he's just giving credit to the
republican voters
but it's like they didn't do it they
just received the money they didn't they
weren't involved in
i have no idea why you did that it
didn't make any sense to me
yeah i wonder if it's like this idea
that maybe he
keeps like giving them credit and naming
them that maybe he can get them on board
later
maybe like i know they're like mcconnell
said he's wriggling a little bit more on
the infrastructure thing i think they
got the republicans up to 800 billion
yeah like um maybe i don't know like
that thing
like if you create expectations for
people they'll live up to it
it's possible but it just seemed very uh
i couldn't explain why i don't know that
was surprising to me yeah no i agree
with you i agree with you
uh all right listen we're on kind of a
delay so i'm gonna i'm gonna
let you go because my audience is
getting ripped [ __ ] they want to call in
and stuff
um hold on david david deepak
yeah you know i gotta ask you oh about
what what's going on uh
how you feeling about all the
israel-palestinian stuff oh fine i mean
every two years this happens and
everybody stakes out
sort of like very black white positions
and then
it cools off after 10 days and then in
two years it happens again
what do you think um how do you feel
about yang's statements about everything
and the internet's reacting to it and i
have like a 10 minute rant about it
today on my bonus show i mean i think it
was like
he seemed to genuinely have no
idea the shitstorm that he was obviously
going to be on the receiving end of
when he tweeted that and then he puts
out this letter and the letter is sort
of like
does it really clarify anything probably
not but honestly my pragmatic take is
i don't think it's going to make a hell
of a difference in the mayoral race in
the end of it
like ultimately ultimately what you know
new york is experiencing
business busts from the pandemic cost of
living
and housing prices are off the charts
public transit
schools you know etc i i just don't
think it's ultimately going to make any
difference
yeah i agree of course um
okay so no hot takes
what do you think um what do you think
the solution is
eventual like big picture yeah i'm kind
of curious what you
feel i've been an advocate for a
two-state solution for a long time which
will never happen
for as long as the two sides are
netanyahu
and a split palestinian
hamas plus palestinian authority i just
don't think that will ever lead to
a sensible um uh
outcome just when you say two-state
solution
like what does that imply in terms of
like government structure and everything
are there different like thoughts
on how this works well i mean it's going
to be one
palestinian government and you have to
make the territories
uh contiguous in some way closely
aligned to the 1967 borders
the one palestinian government can't be
hamas i mean it just
there's no possible way that that's
going to be uh the
the case and um it yeah it would be it'd
be one government and
and sort of with the 67 borders as the
framework
what do you do if um this is really
complicated and if you you've got to
move on soon
what do you what do you do if you hold
more elections in palestine so you get a
unified palestine and hamas ends up
winning elections again
what do you do at that point well okay
we're going back on this or
i don't think that that i don't think
that that will happen
actually if you have a west bank plus
gaza and east jerusalem
that is um all voting to i just don't
think it will happen
but uh certainly if you keep i mean okay
hamas keeps winning in gaza
although there are questions as to
whether that is a completely free and
open way of doing it and that really
reflects the will of the gazans i
question whether it does but
i just don't think the numbers are there
if it's west bank
east jerusalem plus gaza yeah
do you think that our our israelis in
general do you think they would be okay
giving up
east jerusalem permanently um
man that's really true solution without
hamas was reached i
i believe that an eventual two-state
solution
will not have an israeli east jerusalem
so you're i mean i don't know if
i'm not like really answering the
question in the way you're asking it but
i think that
there is not going to be a workable
two-state solution
if east jerusalem is not likely the
capital of that palestinian state
okay yeah um it's rough um i agree with
you that it's a little disappointing
that people seem to stake out like very
black and white positions on it but
um what are you gonna do yeah
um so basically yeah like my opinion's
the same as two years ago because the
same thing is happening as two years ago
good luck with everything um yeah have
fun with your colleagues be careful
all right steven pleasure let's uh check
in again soon
everything have fun all right very good
uh let's see if i can fix my lighting a
little bit i'm gonna take some calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord if you want to talk to me you
can get into the waiting lobby let's see
if i can fix things a little bit
just because things are getting a little
bit kind of weaponized lighting here
let's see where we have people who want
to chat i promise to do it and
i keep my promises right everybody
um let's see
all right let's talk to aiden from new
york aiden you're on the air
hello hello everybody yes i can
hey how you doing doing well i'm
actually very nervous
now oh you're doing great don't worry
all right yeah
so uh this may be a little off talking
off your uh stream by the way um
what's your opinion on uh do we have
some form of a call
loan perform any possible way sorry did
you say student loan reform
yeah it's doing loaded for me that's
what i'm not sorry yeah so i mean listen
uh
i have said before that in terms of just
like paying off student loans
student loan forgiveness i'm open to
some degree of forgiveness but i don't
think that there's a good case for just
paying off everybody's student loans
period
i've just not seen a good case made to
do that and i also don't think it would
solve the problem of the outrageous cost
of college
and in fact it may perpetuate the
problem um
so i think we need to really dig into
the cost of college and we need to look
at
degrees and industries in which wages
have simply not kept up with the cost of
the degree
yeah uh actually i know um my family uh
some of my cousins
uh when they get older at college uh
they may not be able to afford college
so
yes big thing for me i think
increasingly people will forgo college
and that will cause a split where if you
skip
college but you know your parents are
entrepreneurs
or whatever and it's not a field where
you need a degree like medicine or law
you're going to do fine that's the
reality and
for people who don't have that
privileged position they won't be able
to afford going to college
and they won't and they'll end up you
know in worse shape as a result i i
pretty i believe that that's going to
happen
but i thought that you know the economy
changing so much where you need a
college degree you have to go to college
i think there's going to be pushback i
think there's going to be a reversal on
that and you're already starting to see
it in some industries
interesting also um i'm actually from
new york and the big
muriel for new york city uh who do you
think uh you prefer to win the election
i'm not i don't know about prefer
because i don't i don't vote in new york
right now and i don't even know all the
people that are running
i think the numbers are looking very
good for andrew yang
although if all there's a lot of
undecideds right now so if a lot of the
undecideds
unite behind one person they have a very
good shot
i mean i know he's not going to do the
uh what was a universal basic income
yeah campaign yeah i don't think you'd
be able to do that in new york because i
mean i know
new york's a rich state but you wouldn't
be able to afford it
uh i don't know about that i don't know
about that but i don't know that he's
planning to do it yeah
yeah and uh um i don't think i really
had another question so
all right thank you aiden great to talk
to you there is aiden
let's now talk to uh who else do we want
to talk to
let's talk to nee ye from
madrid niyyi you are on the air
hey hi david that was perfect actually
you pronounced it very well
thank you yeah hi so
i kind of not not to go back on the
whole you know israel palestine thing
but um
i'm actually uh black british on my jury
and like on social media you know you
have all the black lives matter
stuff and like you mentioned people are
taking very like you know
black and white stances with uh with
this current issue
and it kind of like i feel a lot of
pressure to kind of put my stance as
well but it's not really
there's a bit of a grade there it's not
quite the same as racism
sorry you're saying you feel pressure to
put your opinion on social media
yeah exactly yeah because you know
because people would support
black lives matter on on the other side
whereas it's not it's not quite the same
as racism like you know i think everyone
can agree that racism is bad
whereas you know it's quite there's a
bit more nuance in this situation
instead
yeah but so why are you feeling pressure
to post about it though
well because you know people can they'll
be like well you know i supported
you know black lives matter so why can't
you support the palestinians
oh oh so they're drawing an equivalency
of some kind
yeah exactly oh i see and is that does
that resonate with you or does that seem
like a false equivalence um
yeah i think it's false because you know
like i said racism is clearly a bad
thing right whereas
with this i mean you can you can argue
that palestine and hamas are very
aggressive and you can argue that you
know
israel is the oppressor so there's a you
know
you can basically integrate in different
ways i see what you're saying
so what are you doing are you staking
out a position or are you just not
talking about it on social
i'm just not talking about it yeah
i understand that um
what's going on in spain
um not too much really as i i live in
madrid and they just recently had uh
elections
and it seems like the the right wing is
still uh growing in power over here so
do an interesting few years to come and
they've just like um removed
the both the um climate change
restrictions they had on on traffic in
the center so
i don't know what's going to happen in
the future more more right-wing stuff
everywhere basically
well it's looking more and more like
i'll be there in uh in august it does
seem that the travel is going to be a
thing so i'm looking forward to it it's
been a few years since i've been
okay that'd be awesome which which city
are you going to probably northwestern
spain galicia that's where i have family
oh okay beautiful area
beautiful area yeah all right my friend
thank you for the call i appreciate it
no thanks thanks for taking it all right
very good
uh let's see who else we've got wanting
to jump in today
uh oh i don't know what about um
what looks interesting what about mark
from los angeles
mark
mark from los angeles you're on the air
all right no mark whatsoever let's try
kevin from seattle seattle you're on the
air
kevin from seattle you're on the air
and kevin is uh gone uh okay
let's try how about ivan from
california david can you hear me
yes i can hey awesome david defect
pac-man
so last time i called um i actually
called interesting enough
on uh on january 6th it was the morning
of
and it was on your live stream and then
uh
we watched the live stream where we
watch the introduction basically unfold
um which is pretty interesting um
anyways so at the time i was kind of
star struck because i was
talking to one of my favorite uh
independent
news media pundits of uh argentinian
descent and
um so i didn't necessarily push back um
i asked basically if he thought um trump
was a fascist
or uh we kind of talked about if it's a
useful label
yeah um and i actually um
i i actually and i actually do think he
was uh i think it's pretty fair to call
um
the republican party fascistic i mean
when you look at the kind of the way
they rally around one leader and um
uh an open disdain for democracy things
like that
um uh what do you think is that salient
or or do you still disagree with that
yeah there's fascistic i mean listen
they are not
fascists in in in practice
i think you can say this is the problem
with just arguing about labels like it
really doesn't change what it is or what
we need to do about it it's like
they have authoritarian leanings they're
extremely nationalistic to a fault
they are fascistic in some of their
ideology yeah sure i mean again it's
you know depending on what the goal is
we would we would contextualize this
based on what we're trying to determine
but like yeah sure i guess you're right
okay awesome um and another thing so
um i i got really into politics during
the 2016 election cycle
and that's when i started to read the
newspaper and all that stuff and um
and so i've kind of heard this uh uh
over the years but is
is the um are we like uniquely polarized
over the last few years
is that something that's kind of been
increasing or is that something that
as someone who's been following this
stuff longer um that everyone in their
generation always feels that they're
polarized or are we in like a unique
situation in the last
the years or so for the last 20 years
you've seen lots of people say this is
the most polarized we've ever been now
it's possible that we've just become
become more and more and more polarized
over time and so that it was correct
all along uh i think that
i can't say whether the country is more
polarized than ever but what i could say
with some certitude is that
the vast majority of the political
discourse
is about the differences rather than the
points of agreement which makes sense it
makes for better tv
and it gets people more riled up so i
think that
um talking focusing on
the the polarization has become
more present whether it's actually
representative of more polarization or
just the polarization is more visible
i don't really know interesting
okay yeah it's something interesting
also thinking about
yeah uh one last quick thing if you
don't mind sure very quick
um uh would you ever or uh have you ever
thought about
uh reaching out and trying to be on bill
maher because he's pretty okay on a lot
of points but
he kind of uh uh accepts some really bad
talking points like with like cancel
culture and stuff like that and i think
it'd be cool to have a progressive on
there
i would appear anytime i've never been
invited but i would be glad to appear
anytime
interesting okay thank you peace peace
all right peace and love thank you very
much
um okay let's talk to
um why don't we talk to
beppers from minnesota beppers you're on
the air
oh uh hello hello
so i have a question about vaccinations
so
i got my second dose a couple days ago
but i was wondering how do you think
the government is going to handle uh
people who
refuse to get vaccinated like even if it
just keeps getting tested and it keeps
getting better and better
like how do you think that's going to
pan out i don't think the government is
going to force anybody to get vaccinated
i think that increasingly you will have
uh schools
and some employers who will say our
students our employees must be
vaccinated
you'll have countries that will say if
you want to travel to our country here's
the list of vaccines you need and they
will add
the covet vaccine to that list and i
think that there will be some people who
choose never to get vaccinated and
they'll be allowed to do that that that
that'll basically be it i think we will
handle the pandemic but that the
unvaccinated people will remain
at a higher level of risk for the
foreseeable future
so you're saying it's going to be more
at a
private level than and less federal
yeah the federal gov governments are not
going to force people to get vaccinated
okay and by that i mean american
governments like the american federal
what other countries i don't know what
other countries will do state government
municipal government federal government
in the u.s will not force people to be
vaccinated
hello okay beppers
from minnesota there it is let's go next
to
dank from washington you're on the air
ah hello pacman long time listener first
time caller thank you
uh i was interested in uh in june the
pentagon has to release information on
the uf the ufo phenomenon that's been
going on
i was wondering if you were going to
cover that or if that's even in your
wheelhouse of
uh caring i know nothing about it i know
nothing about it i mean listen
at some point if i'm alive and it's
announced that there has been first
contact
uh that will be a life-changing story
but i i mean
you know i hear a little bit about this
will be released that will be released
remember ufo doesn't mean aliens
so i'm just not paying too much
attention to it and i'm sure if there is
verifiable
news uh i will hear of it
and uh okay yeah that's pretty much all
i was interested if like that was kind
of if you heard about it if you were
interested about it or
whatnot yeah i mean listen it would be a
massive thing for society without
question but
yeah i'm sure i'll hear i don't need to
be like looking around for that
information because that would be
one of the biggest news stories to ever
happen
anywhere in the history of time so i
know i'll know about it if it happens
all right all right well thank you all
right dank
from washington appreciate it let's go
next
to austin from illinois or maybe it's
illinois from austin i don't know
uh yeah you're right it's it's actually
to pronounce illinois
uh there's a silent e on the end um
so i've got a question about uh
carbon tax carbon pricing is there any
appetite
like in the united states for it because
it would be
a very efficient way of meeting a lot of
the goals we have on the environment
i think there's an appetite so let's see
how i can say this
i think there is not an appetite for
something called a carbon tax
but i think there is racing i think
there is an
appetite for the idea of having to
pay in proportion to the amount of
pollution that you create
yeah because if if okay now this is a
big year
yeah if the republican party
acknowledged the risks of climate change
it would be a very
fiscally conservative way of approaching
it you know it's kind of free market
yes you know i think it could be
something that could be gotten behind
if they acknowledge reality i agree with
you completely yeah i just think that
it's the issue of
carbon tax just on name alone
is something that um the the right would
oppose
uh massively yeah
totally agree and then something a
little different are you familiar with
strong towns at all
no uh it's a grassroots like
urban planning uh like local involvement
thing
uh they've got a founder that he
he talks a lot about infrastructure
charles marone
and i think he he could be interesting
if if you could get him on the show
uh just from her local infrastructure
perspective he's he's
a little conservative in a classical
conservative way in some of his
approaches but i think he's a very
interesting voice
all right i will look into it this is
the first i've heard of it i will
investigate
all right thank you all right thank you
very much uh okay thanks everybody
that's gonna do it for calls today
really strong stream today and i so
appreciate everybody who joined me
uh people who hated that i talked to
destiny i'm sorry
people who liked it uh thank you and uh
you know so on and so forth so that's
gonna do it for me today
but we're going to be back before you
know it uh and
i am sending greetings of peace and love
from the new
bunker which is not really a bunker it's
sort of it's kind of the opposite it's
very airy and nice
all right everybody see you soon